हेलो
एवरीवन एंड गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
ओके सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है आई एम
लाउड एंड
क्लियर अमित आईम आई एम
फाइन ओके अमरीश वेरी गुड
इवनिंग सुशांता वेरी गुड
इवनिंग रूपेश वेरी गुड इवनिंग
नहीं आवाज तो कम नहीं है
यार ओके वेरी गुड इनिंग वेरी गुड
इवनिंग सभी को क्लास में मजा आ रहा है
एंजॉय कर रहे हो
सबको कुछ ना कुछ सीखने को मिल ही रहा
होगा थोड़ा सा वेट करते
हैं बाकी स्टूडेंट के आने
का फिर क्लास को कंटिन्यू करेंगे और आज जो
एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन का प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट है
व हम कंप्लीट कर
देंगे नहीं साउंड कम नहीं है यार मेरी तरफ
से फुल वॉल्यूम है
आप अपनी तरफ चेक
कीजिए यस मेरे सब सेटिंग सही है
क्या बोल रहे हो आप
नहीं यार साउंड मेरा कभी भी कम नहीं आता
मैं हमेशा क्रॉस चेक करता हूं वीडियो
कंप्लीट करने के बावजूद मेरे आईपैड में
मेरे मोबाइल्स में कहीं पर भी मुझे कहीं
पर भी साउंड कम नहीं दिखाई दिया इसको मैं
100 नहीं कर सकता अगर मैं 100 करूंगा तो
आपको साउंड फटा हुआ सुनाई देगा तो ओनली हम
इतना ही रख सकते हैं तो दिस इज द बेस्ट
सेटिंग कई बार क्या होता कि अगर आप आप
अपनी तरफ से देख रहे हो तो
youtube2 ही रख सकता हूं इससे ज्यादा
रखूंगा तो कोई फायदा नहीं है
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं दो मिनट का बाकी
लोगों को जवाइन होने देते
हैं देर ओनली 25 स्टूडेंट्स
जिसकी एक्सपेक्टेशन नहीं होती वे
स्टूडेंट्स है
य दीपक
आपका सवाल समझ नहीं पाया आप क्या पूछने की
कोशिश कर रहे
हो हेलो राकेश
हेलो तो मुझे यह बता दीजिए आज क्लास में
कितने
नए स्टूडेंट हैं जो फर्स्ट टाइम जिनकी
क्लास
आज
बताइए सबाइल
ओके और कोई
दीपक वो तो आप पर डिपेंड करता है कि आपका
इंटरेस्ट कितना है कि आप कितना इंटरेस्टेड
हो इस फील्ड में कि कहने से इंटरेस्ट नहीं
होता इंटरेस्ट बनाने से होता है कि आप
कितना मतलब कि अगर आपको सिर्फ यही चीज
करने के लिए छोड़ा जाए तो आप कितनी देर तक
फोकस कर सकते हो बोर नहीं होते
या कितनी कितना फोकस्ड हो अपने पैशन से
रिलेटेड क्योंकि एथिकल सेकिंग सीखना
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग सीखना या साइबर
सिक्योरिटी सीखना एक पैशनेट जॉब है जैसे
कि मेरे को अगर कोई बो बोले कि आपको क्लास
भी रेडी करनी और साथ में पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग भी करनी है तो आई कां आई कैन डू
24 * 7 मतलब 24 आवर्स में कंटीन्यूअसली एक
जगह पर बैठकर कर सकता हूं दिस इज माय
फेवरेट टॉपिक एंड माय
बोल सकते हो कि माय फेवरेट जॉब या माय
फेवरेट पैशन पैशन तो आई एम वेरी पैशनेट
अबाउट इट तो इसलिए मुझे कभी भी यह चीज
बोरिंग नहीं लगती मैं हमेशा कुछ ना कुछ
नया सीखने की कोशिश करता हूं इसी फील्ड
में कोई नई वलन बिलिटी मिलती है कोई न
आर्टिकल उससे रिलेटेड मिलता है तो उसको
मैं रिसर्च करता हूं अगर रिसर्च कंटिन्यू
टू थ्री फोर हाव चलेगी तो नो इशू आई विल
टोटल फोकस इ सब कुछ भूल जाता हूं तो दिस
इज द पैशनेट अबाउट योर अभी आप पर डिपेंड
करता है कि आपका अगर फोर्सफुली आए हो किसी
के कहने पर आए हो आपका इंटरेस्ट नहीं है
तो फिर आपके लिए प्रॉब्लम है तो पहले आपका
इंटरेस्ट होना चाहिए आप अपना इंटरेस्ट
ढूंढो इस चीज
में हा काली नेक्स में मेटा स्ट फ्रेमवर्क
की इशू आ रहे हैं तो पैरेट ओस को यूज करो
या पुराने वालो एक काम करो वर्जन
डाउनग्रेड कर दो
यस फील द स्पार्क आप वर्जन डाउनग्रेड कर
दो या अभी के लिए पैरेट आज मैं पैरेट ओस
सी वर्जन यूज वजह से कर रहा हूं क्योंकि
पता नहीं काली में अभी
फ्लक्शनल में फ्लकचुएशन कर रहा है कल
लास्ट क्लास में ने देखा था बिफोर डे कि
एक दिन पहले जो क्लास थी डेट 12 की बात है
तो उसमें हमारा पूरा एमएसएफ कंसोल की वजह
से पूरा कॉलेज सिस्टम वो कर रहा
था
ओके तो अभी क्लास स्टार्ट करेंगे क्लास
स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं बता देता हूं जो
नए स्टूडेंट्स हैं जिनकी फर्स्ट क्लास है
सेकंड क्लास है अगर उनको नहीं पता तो हम
बता देते हैं इस कोर्स का नाम है डे
फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर्स एसेंशियल्स जिसको
रिनेम कर दिया गया था हमने डीसी जीएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल से अभी आपको हम बता देते हैं
कि अगर आपको कंपनी से रिलेटेड कहीं पर भी
कोई कुछ भी न्यूज़ चाहिए कि आपको कंपनी
अभी क्या प्लान कर रही है क्या कोई जॉब
रिक्वायरमेंट ऐड कर रही है यह सारी चीजें
डेनिक्स कंपनी से रिलेटेड तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो डेनिक्स अकेडमी को विजिट कर सकते
हो दिस इज आवर यह हमारी वेबसाइट है de.com
तो यहां पर आपको सारी अपडेट चीजें मिलती
है कोई भी कोर्स लच होता उससे रिलेटेड भी
आपको अपडेट इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर मिलती है
या आपको इस क्लास के रिसोर्सेस में अभी
क्या है कि लास्ट दो क्लासेस से हम
प्रैक्टिकल्स कर रहे हैं तो हमारे पास कोई
भी पीपीटी यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ी है
लेकिन अगर हमें पीपीटी जरूरत करते हैं
जरूरत पड़ती है या हम यूज करते हैं तो उस
टाइम हम हमने क्या किया हुआ है कि एक
पोर्टल ओपन किया हुआ है कि गो टू योर
अकेडमी टैब गो टू फ्री रिसोर्सेस आपको
सिंपली क्या करना है यहां पर डीएचसी
सर्टिफिकेट नोट्स यहां पर आप इसको एनरोल
करना है जस्ट पे योर 0 यहां पर आपको सारे
रिसोर्सेस सारे नोट्स मिलेंगे जो क्लास के
बाद अपडेट हो जाते हैं और दूसरी चीज यहां
पर क्या मिलेगी आपको सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा
तीसरी चीज आपको यहां पर क्या मिलेगी आने
वाले टाइम में इसी कोर्स को हम क्या करने
वाले कुछ नमरे फेज या स्कैनिंग फेज के बाद
हम क्या करने वाले इस कोर्स को लाइव मतलब
होंगे सभी के सभी स्टूडेंट क्या कर सकते
हैं उस
[संगीत]
आईडी है प्रोफाइल है आपको सिंपली क्या
करना है डेनिक्स क्योंकि जो भी अभी मैं
टास्क बताने वाला हूं जो भी लैब्स आपको
सॉल्व करने के लिए बताऊंगा या जो भी आपको
असाइनमेंट दूंगा आपको सिंपली क्या सॉल्व
करने है और डे फोनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
अकेडमी को टैग करना है दिस इज द डे फोनिक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी पेज है ये उसका पेज है
लिंकन पेज है ओके तीसरी चीज क्या है कि
अभी आपको नहीं पता आप नए स्टूडेंट्स हो
आपको नहीं पता कि सर मुझे नेक्स्ट क्लास
कब आएगी या कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन
से अपडेटेड होना है कि नेक्स्ट क्लास कब
है नेक्स्ट कोर्स कौन सा है कुछ भी
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए आपको रिलेटेड टू द डेफ
अकैडमी एक हमारा
whatsapp2 पर सर्च करना है डेनिक्स तो
ऑटोमेटिक वहां पर डेनिक्स हाईलाइट होके आ
जाता है आपको सर्च करते ही दूसरी अगर आपको
वहां से नहीं जाना है तो आपको क्या करना
है सिंपली किसी भी कोर्सेस को जैसे डे 12
में हम गए यहां पर और सिंपली हम क्या करें
रीड मोर और यहां पर यह रहा जॉइन र
क्लिक ऑन द
whatsapp2 की क्लास कब होगी ओके नेक्स्ट
कोर्स कौन सा आने वाला है या हम हमने जो
भी कुछ प्लान किया है उसके अपडेट वो सब
कुछ हम यहां पर भी शेयर करते हैं तो ये दो
तीन जगह है जहां पर आपको डेफिनेटली होना
चाहिए डेफ के साथ अगर आप कंटीन्यूअसली
इंफॉर्मेशन लेना चाहते हो तो तो ये कुछ
इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन ी जो मैं आपको
प्रोवाइड कर रहा था
देखिए काली लिनक्स और पैरेट ओस ये एक
लिनक्स डेवियन बेस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है
जो स्पेशली फॉर क्या है आपके पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग के लिए है ओके वीएम वेयर क्या
आपका एक वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट आप क्या करते
हो कि आप एक साथ क्या है अगर आपको काली
नेक्स भी यूज करना है पैरेट ओस भी यूज
करना है तो आपको क्या करना पड़ता है
आपको काली के लिए अलग से लैपटॉप लेना
पड़ेगा या कंप्यूटर लेना पड़ेगा या पैरेट
के लिए अलग से कंप्यूटर लेना पड़ेगा या
उनको ल बूट क्रिएट करना पड़ेगा अब ये
प्रॉब्लमैटिक है अभी क्या है कि वीएम वेर
या वर्चुअल बॉक्स की हेल्प से क्या कर
सकते हो आप अपनी एसिस्टिंग जो विंडोज मशीन
है उसके अंदर मल्टीपल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
यूज कर सकते हो जैसे मेरी ये विंडोज है
विंडोज के अंदर मैं क्या कर रहा हूं ये
वीएम वेर है ये वर्चुअल वर्चुअल बॉक्स है
मेरा मतलब वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट है क्लिक
किया यहां पर मैं यूज कर सकता हूं जैसे कि
ये रही यहां पर मेरा यह रहा पैट ओ काली ओ
एकस यह मेरा सर्वर है विंडोज सर्वर है इसी
तरीके से एक और मेरा लैपटॉप है जिसमें चार
मशीने और हैं तो इस तरीके से हम मल्टीपल
मशीन को यूज कर सकते हैं अपने प्रैक्टिस
के लिए अदर वाइज अगर हमारे पास वर्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट नहीं होता तो हमें तीन मशीन
तीन लैपटॉप इन के लिए चाहिए होते और तीन
लैपटॉप दूसरा हमें छह या सात लैपटॉप चाहिए
होते हैं एक चीज के लिए तो उस चीज को
ओवरकम करने के लिए हमने वर्चुअल
एनवायरमेंट का यूज करते हैं क्लियर
ओके क्लास को स्टार्ट करते
हैं तो आज क्लास 28 क्लास में 28 स्टूडेंट
है तो आज मैं आपको यह नहीं बता रहा कि
नेक्स्ट क्लास कब होगी अभी नेक्स्ट क्लास
में अपनी मर्जी से लूंगा क्योंकि अभी आप
लोग रिस्पांसिबल हो इस चीज के लिए या
ग्रुप रिस्पांसिबल है मैं इस क्लास को
डिले करूंगा अभी कोर्स मुझे अगर मैं मैं
इस कोर्स को कोर्स की तरह से चला रहा था
जैसे एक पेड कोर्स होता है एक दिन के बाद
एक दिन कोर्स चलाते हैं ना ऐसे पेड कोर्स
की तरह हम चलाने की कोशिश कर रहे थे कि
डेली क्लासेस की बजाय हम एक दिन छोड़ के
ताकि आपको प्रैक्टिस करने का टाइम मिल जाए
बट आप लोग नहीं डिजर्व करते आप लोग नहीं
चाहते ये सारी चीजें तो इट्स ओके अभी
नेक्स्ट क्लास में अभी चार महीने में
कोर्स को खत्म करता अभी मैं चार की बजाय 8
महीने 10 महीने में खत्म करूंगा य मेरी
मर्जी है कोर्स को मैं क्लोज नहीं कर रहा
बट यह मेरी मर्जी है क्योंकि आप अपनी
मर्जी कर सकते तो मैं भी अपनी मर्जी
करूंगा क्योंकि आईम टोटली डी मोटिवेट
फ्रॉम एवरी
बडी तो लास्ट क्लास में हमने ब्रूट फोर्स
अटैक किया था एसएमबी के ऊपर और वहां से
हमने क्रेडेंशियल फाइंड आउट किए थे वो भी
एडमिन के क्रेडेंशियल हमें मिल गए थे अगर
सबको याद होगा तो क्रेडेंशियल कौन-कौन से
थे और हमने ब्रूट फोर्स किसके थ्रू किया
था और कौन सा मॉड्यूल यूज किया था जल्दी
से चैट में बताइए जल्दी
से लास्ट क्लास में हमने डिस्कस किया था
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक किया था कि ब्रूट फोर्स
अटक करने के लिए
हमने क्या क्या स्टेप परफॉर्म किए थे या
कौन सा मॉड्यूल यूज किया था और कौन से
क्रेडेंशियल हमें मिले थे
बताइए क्या किसी को भी नहीं
पता वे ग्रेंट क्या था यूजर नेम था
पासवर्ड
था कॉमिनेशन मिला था ना ओके गुड साइबर
सिक्स यू आर ऑन द राइट
पाथ ओके पैरेट वस में किया था लेकिन यूज
क्या किया था
हमने या वेरी गुड जगत गुरु स्वामी आपका
असली नाम क्या है प्लीज बताना एक बार आप
हर क्लास को अटेंड करते हो
या वेरी गुड
कार्बन नहीं एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर नेम था
और वैग्रांट पासवर्ड
था ओके राजेश गुड नेम तो अभी हम कंटिन्यू
करते हैं देखिए हमारे पास इंफॉर्मेशन है
क्योंकि हमने विंडोज मशीन को क्या किया है
ब्रूट फोर्स किया है एसएमबी उनके एसएमबी
क्रेडेंशियल को और हमारे पास क्या है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एंड पासवर्ड में क्या है
वेगें अभी इस इंफॉर्मेशन को यूज करके हम
फर्द क्या कर सकते हैं और भी इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं कैसे उसके लिए हमें
यूज करना होगा ए मैप का कुछ और स्क्रिप्ट
ए मैप हा अभी मैं पिंग कर लेते हैं एक बार
सबसे पहले हम पिंग
192.168 डट
222 देखिए ये मेरा पिंग हो रहा है ओके गुड
इट्स वर्किंग तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं ए
मैप हान प पोर्ट 445 ओके 445 यूज कर रहे
हैं देन उसके बाद हम यूज करें स्क्रिप्ट
कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट यूज
करेंगे स्क्रिप्ट वो स्क्रिप्ट का नाम है
एसएमबी एनम सेशंस ओके एसएमबी एनम
सेशंस एसएमबी हाइ फन
एनम सेशंस यह आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी बनती
है कि एसएमबी एनम सेशन जो एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट है उसकी वर्किंग क्या है वो
क्या इंफॉर्मेशन आपको फाइंड आउट करके देती
है
ओके अभी हमारे पास क्रेडेंशियल है तो मैं
यूजर्स नेम और पासवर्ड एन मैप में एज ए
आर्गुमेंट क्या कर सकता हूं प्रोवाइड कर
सकता हूं कैसे उसके लिए एक फ्लैग होता है
हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट हाइन आर् ए
आर जी एस आर्गुमेंट देन उसके बाद
एसएमबी एसएमबी यूजर नेम यह सब जब आप
पढ़ोगे एसएमबी एनम सेशन तो उसके अंदर
बताया आप आर्गुमेंट कैसे दे सकते हो
बिल्कुल डिटेल्स में बताया गया होगा इक्वल
टू एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडी एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर देन उसके बाद
एसएमबी मैं इसको एक काम कर देता हूं थोड़ा
सा बड़ा कर देता हूं एसएमबी उसके बाद
पासवर्ड
पासवर्ड उसके बाद इक्वल है उसका ी ए जी आर
ए एन टी वे ग्रेंट ओके एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर या
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हा एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ही था
देन उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
168.0 222 हिट एंटर कीजिए अभी देखना
ओके मैं जूम कर देता हूं थोड़ा सा और
लो नाउ अभी इस स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू हमें
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली हमने क्या किया एसएमबी
एनम सेसम यूजर लगड इन ओके यूजर लॉग इन गगन
आ2 कब से लॉग इन किया है अभी
नाउ ये रहा एक्टिव एसएमबी सेशन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर इज कनेक्टेड फ्रॉम
192.168 1660 से हमने कंफर्म कर लिया कि
यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड क्या है सही है अभी
मैं और इंफॉर्मेशन निकालता हूं शेयर की
इंफॉर्मेशन तो शेयर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे
निकालू एन मैप हाइन प पट 445 हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट होती है एस
एनम हाइन शेयर्स हाइन शेयर्स उसके बाद अभी
यह पास कर द हम आर्गुमेंट में यह सारी
चीज कॉपी और यहां पर हम क्या कर पेस्ट कर
देंगे देख लीजिए एक
बार एन मैप पोट 445 स्क्रिप्ट एसबी एनम
शेयर आर्गुमेंट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एंड
पासवर्ड क्योंकि अभी हमारे पास यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड है तो उससे हमें और भी ज्यादा
फॉर्मेशन मिलेगी कौन-कौन से शेयर्स है या
कौन शे क्रिएट नहीं हुए हैं तो अभी हम
इसको क्या करते हैं हिट एंटर देखिए
अभी ना अभी देखि इसके ऊपर कौन-कौन से शेयर
है देखो एसएमबी एनम शेयर्स अकाउंट यूज
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एक तो यह शेयर है
एडमिन उसके बाद कमेंट रिमोट एडमिन उसके
बाद यह रहा ना सेकंड शेयर क्या है सी और
थर्ड शेयर क्या है
आईपीसी बस अभी इनके अलावा अभी यहां पर
देखो रीड एंड राइट एक्सेस है रीड एंड राइट
एक्सेस है रीड एंड राइट एक्सेस है अभी एक
चीज आप नोटिस करोगे विंडोज के अंदर जब भी
आप क्या करते हो
एसएमबी एक्टिवेट करते हो कोई भी शेयर
क्रिएट करते हो तो बाय डिफॉल्ट ये आपको
मिलेंगे ही मिलेंगे यह जब भी शेयर्स की जो
इसके रिलेटेड परमिशन एसएमबी से रिलेटेड जो
बोल सकते हैं सर्विसेस है जब उनको क्या
करोगे ऑन करते हो तो एडमिन सी और यह
आईपीसी आपको बाय डिफॉल्ट ओन ही मिलेंगे
अभी इसकी एक कहानी है अभी मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन नहीं कर सकता क् इसकी कहानी
समझाने बैठ जाऊंगा तो ऐसे आपको समझ में
नहीं आएगी
क्योंकि यह वर्किंग प्रिंसिपल आता है
विंडोज का इंटरनल जो जो विंडोज का इंटरनल
नेटवर्क सिस्टम है ना विंडोज का जो इंटरनल
कैसे काम करता है यह उसके अंदर की कहानी
है और अभी मैं इसको समझा नहीं सकता अगर आप
लोग इंटरेस्टेड हो तो आप खुद से रिसर्च
कीजिए या फिर कभी हम याद रखिए यह कोर्स के
बीच में या कोर्स के एंड में कभी स्पेशल
सेशन ले आएंगे कि विंडोज का इंटरनल
नेटवर्क सिस्टम कैसे काम करता है क्योंकि
एक इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है ये अपने आप में
और जब आप वो पढ़ोगे ना विंडोज के
फंडामेंटल का पार्ट है ये और एज ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट आपको विंडोज के फंडा
फंडामेंटल बिल्कुल क्लियर होने चाहिए अगर
आपको विंडोज के फंडामेंटल क्लियर नहीं है
ना तो आप बिल्कुल भी विंडोज के ऊपर पन
टेस्टिंग नहीं कर पाओगे क्योंकि विदाउट
फंडामेंटल्स आपको कुछ समझ में नहीं आएगा
अभी ये कहानी आपको समझ में नहीं आरही
क्योंकि ये क्या बाय डिफॉल्ट वाले हैं
क्योंकि अलग से कोई भी इसमें शेयर क्रिएट
नहीं किया गया ओनली य सर्विस रनिंग है समझ
पा रहे हो जो मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर रहा
हूं लेकिन ये इसकी एक अपनी कहानी है
सर्विसेस कैसे कंपलसरी कंडीशन ये विंडो की
कहानी है तो ये आपको समझनी पड़ेगी या तो
खुद से रिसर्च कीजिए या फिर कभी मैं इसके
ऊपर ंग कर रहा था तो वेरी सरप्राइज की ऐसे
काम करता है क्योंकि
ओके तो मैं आपके कमेंट की तरफ ध्यान चला
गया था
तो सॉरी फॉर
दैट तो अभी हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं तो अभी
यूजर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करते क्योंकि हमारे पास क्रेडेंशियल
है तो ए मैप हान पोट 445 देन एक स्क्रिप्ट
यूज
करेंगे उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट का नाम है
एसएमबी
एनम यूजर्स एसएमबी एनम
यूजर्स देन उसके बाद फिर से हम क्या करते
हैं कट कॉपी पेस्ट कर देते हैं ऑलरेडी
हमने कट कट कॉपी कॉपी किया हुआ है तो
पेस्ट कर देते हैं ना ये रहा फिर से हिट
एंटर करते हैं अभी यहां पर देखिए यूजर्स
की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल जाएगी ये रहा
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स
दिस इज ये बिल्ट इन कंप्लीट अकाउंट नॉर्मल
यूजर अकाउंट दिस इज द एक और यूजर अकाउंट
दिस वन दिस वन दिस वन
नाउ गेस्ट यूजर अकाउंट दज आर द यूजर
अकाउंट इनसाइड देयर तो यह सारे के सारे
क्या है यूजर्स है अब यह देखो यह रहा एक
वेगें फुल नेम वे ग्रेंट डिस्क्रिप्शन
वेगें यूजर्स फ्लैग क्या है नॉर्मल यूजर
अकाउंट पासवर्ड डज नॉट एक्सपायर अब यहां
पर और भी इंफॉर्मेशन कि इनका पासवर्ड
एक्सपायर नहीं होगा मतलब कहने का मतलब
क्या कि अगर आपने एक बार कनेक्शन बना लिया
अगर इनका आपने ब्रूट फोर्स सक्सेसफुली कर
लिया आपको सक्सेसफुली आईडिया मिल कि ब्रूट
फोर्स हो गया तो अभी आपको क्या इनकी
पासवर्ड पॉलिसी के हिसाब से इनका पासवर्ड
कभी भी एक्सपायर नहीं होता तो आपको बारबार
क्या ब्रूट फोर्स करने की जरूरत नहीं होगी
ओके तो यह यूजर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
कर सकते हो ए मैप के थ्रू और भी बहुत कुछ
कर सकते हो जैसे कि आप और भी स्क्रिप्ट है
ए मैप हाइन हाइन पोर्ट
445 हाइन
हाइन स्क्रिप्ट देन एक और स्क्रिप्ट है
आपकी एसएमबी एनम देन उसके बाद
डोमस डोमस उसके बाद फिर से कंट्रोल शिफ्ट
व हिट एंटर
ना यहां पर आपको देखो डोमन की इंफॉर्मेशन
है गग 2000 आ2
एंड ओके यह रहा यूजर्स एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर य य
पर य प इंफॉर्मेशन मिल ग देखो एक ग्रुप की
इंफॉर्मेशन येय रही दीज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ
यूजर्स इसमें क्या दो यूजर्स है एक तो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स और वेगें बाकी क्या इसके
सर्विसेस भी हो सकती है स जैसे एसएसएचडी
एसएसएचडी सर्वर तो यह सर्विसेस की
इंफॉर्मेशन है नाउ उसके बाद ग्रुप
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स बैकअप ऑपरेटर एंड देर
लॉट ऑफ अदर्स एंड यूजर्स यह भी एक ग्रुप्स
है तो यह आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन आ गई आपकी
रिलेटेड टू द डोमस तो और भी बहुत सारी
चीजें आप यूज कर सकते हो जैसे कि इसके
अंदर मैं आप स्क्रिप्ट के नाम बता देता
हूं एन मैप हाइन प एक और है हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट हान हान स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद है
एसएमबी एनम
ग्रुप्स यह वाली स्क्रिप्ट आप यूज कर सकते
हो
देन उसके अलावा यह रहा हमारी कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट यह
रहा एसम बी एनम नाउ प स्पेस ओके पोर्ट
हमने यहां
पर ओके वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट
वेट पोर्ट हम मेंशन करना भूल गए
यहां पर दे ग्रुप्स की इंफॉर्मेशन है तो
आप ग्रुप्स की इंफॉर्मेशन भी फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो विद द हेल्प ऑफ दिस एसएमबी जो
एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट है इसकी हेल्प से यहा
देखो एसएमबी एनम ग्रुप्स और भी आप स्कप
यूज कर सकते हो जैसे कि आपको नाम बता देता
हूं मैं अभी क्लियर कर देता ब स्क्रीन को
नाउ ननो उसके
बाद डेमो डटी एक्सटी
ना अभी और भी आप कौन स्कप यूज कर सकते हो
एक तो मैंने आपको
बताई एसएमबी एनम उसके बाद आप यूज कर सकते
हो ग्रुप्स ग्रुप्स आपको मैंने बताया देन
उसके बाद बता रहा हूं मैं एसएमबी हाइ फन
सर्वर य आपको खुद से यूज करके देखनी है
हापन सर्वर
स्टेटस एसटी स्टेटस देन उसके बाद एसएमबी
हाइन उसके बाद आप यूज कर सकते हो एनम
डोमन डोमेन इन आपको अगर स्पेलिंग की
मिस्टेक मिलती है तो प्लीज आप खुद से कैक
कर लेना उसके बाद आप यूज कर सकते हो
एसएमबी मैं आपको नाम बताता एसएमबी एनम
उसके बाद आप यूज कर सकते हो सर्विसेस आप
सर्विसेस की इंफॉर्मेशन भी फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो देन उसके
बाद एसएमबी एनम
शेयर्स शेयर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो तो यह सारी सारी क्या है और भी
स्क्रिप्ट आप यूज कर सक सकते हो जो मैं
आपको लिस्ट आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं कर
रहा हूं आप क्या कर सकते हो अभी इसका
स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए प्लीज टेक
स्क्रीनशॉट प्लीज टेक ए स्क्रीनशॉट
ओके अभी यह बकवास नहीं
करेगा तो सबने स्क्रीनशॉट ले लिया इसका
एवरीवन एवरीवन टेक द स्क्रीनशॉट
बताइए चैट में रिप्लाई कीजिए
प्लीज
ओके तो अभी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं क्लोज
करता हूं ट्रोल
एक्स
यस
नाउ स्क्रीन को क्लियर करते हैं एक टूल
होता है सबने सुना होगा एसएमबी मैप एसएमबी
मैप अगर हमारे पास क्रेडेंशियल है तो उस
टूल को हम यूज कर सकते हैं तो अभी आपको
मेन पेज ओपन करके दिखा देता हूं एसएमबी
मैप का यह रहा यह इसका मेन मेन पेज है
मतलब मैनुअल है आप पढ़ सकते होय क्या
एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन टूल है
डिस्कशन एसएमबी एसएमबी मैप अलाउ यूजर टू
नमरे साबा शेयर डिवाइस अक्रॉस ए
एंटायस लिस्ट शेयर ड्राइव्स ड्राइव परमिश
शेयर कंटेंट्स अपलोड डाउनलोड फंक्शनल फाइल
नेम ऑटो डाउनलोड पैटर्न मैचिंग एंड इवन
एग्जीक्यूट रिमोट कमांड्स दिस टूल वाज
डिजाइंड विद पन टेस्टिंग इन माइंड एंड इज
इंटेंडेड टू सिंपलीफाई सर्चिंग फॉर
पोटेंशियली सेंसिटिव डाटा अक्रॉस लार्ज
नेटवर्क दज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ ऑप्शन जो आप
इसके साथ यूज कर सकते हो हान एच हेल्प
फाइल है हान हान होस्ट फाइल हान य यूजर
नेम हान प पासवर्ड हान ए शेयर हान डी
डोमेन हान प पोर्ट तो यह सारी आप क्या कर
सकते हो एक बार खुद से पढ़ना और हर एक
ऑप्शंस को एक बार पढ़ के देख लेना कि किस
ऑप्शंस का क्या मतलब हो सकता है देखिए
यहां पर हान यू पासवर्ड डी वर्क ग्रुप ये
इस तरीके से आप इस तरीके से इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो इसमें और इसके अंदर
आप कमांड भी एग्जीक्यूट करवा सकते हो अगर
रिमोट आर स वनटी होगी तो ओके तो अभी हम
क्या करते हैं यहां पर क्योंकि आपको जब हम
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करेंगे लैब्स के थ्रू
तो वहां पर काफी हेल्पफुल होगा आपको याद
रखना है तो कैसे यूज कर सकते हैं इसको फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं यूज कर रहा हूं आपको याद
होगा लास्ट क्लास में हमने कि एक चीज
नोटिस की थी कि गेस्ट अकाउंट इनेबल मिला
था कौन सा गेस्ट अकाउंट तो अब मैं क्या
करर हान प 445 देन ना सॉरी अभी हाइन प
मुझे नहीं चाहिए एसएमबी मैप यूज कर रहा हं
हान यू यूजर गेस्ट
गेस्ट अकाउंट है इनेबल था और हाइन प
पासवर्ड अभी मैं क्या प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं
नील खाली ब्लैंक हाइन डी डायरेक्टरी अब
मैं क्या करता हूं डॉट मतलब रूट
डायरेक्टरी उसकी हाइन एच एच का मतलब क्या
है आपको टारगेट स्पेसिफाई करना
192.168 222 हम इसी के ऊपर यूज करने वाले
हैं अभी यहां पर देखना अगर गेस्ट अकाउंट
इनेबल होगा देखो ऑथेंटिकेशन एरर मतलब
गेस्ट अकाउंट इसके ऊपर नहीं है बस यह उसके
रिलेटेड वहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन कुछ मिलती है
गलत भी इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती है तो हमारे
पास वैलिड यूजर नेम पासवर्ड है तो एसएमबी
मैप हाइन य
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हाइ फन प
पासवर्ड हमारे पास क्या था वे
ग्रेंट वेग हमारे पास पासवर्ड था देन उसके
बाद
नडी देन उसके बाद हान एच देन
192.168
0.1 222 सॉरी तो हिट एंटर यहां पर
देखिए अभी देखो पासवर्ड नेम पासवर्ड सही
था और यूजर नेम सही था देखिए यहां पर अब
ये एक आपको एक अच्छे फॉर्मेट बताएगा देखो
एडमिन डिस्क रीड एंड राइट परमिशन रिमोट
एडमिन सी एक सी शेयर है रीड एंड राइट
डिफॉल्ट शेयर आईपीसी नो एक्सेस रिमोट
आईपीसी ओके तो ये इफ मतलब एक्स्ट्रा कोई
भी शेयर इसके ऊपर अभी
क्रिएटेडॉक्युमेंट्सफ्रैगमेंट
[संगीत]
हम इसको हटा देता
हूं सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी कहां जाएगा अरे
यार मत भाग
इतना
ओके हान x का यूज करना ऑप्शन का और यहां
पर आप क्या मेंशन करोगे कमांड मेंशन करोगे
मैसे क्या आईपी
कॉन्फिन फिग अगर यहां पर वनटी होगी तो ये
कमांड एग्जीक्यूट कर जाएगी और दिस इज अ
वेरी पोटेंशियल वेरी डेंजरस वलन बिलिटी
ओके हिट एंटर
देखिए वर्किंग वर्किंग वर्किंग
वर्किंग यस सक्सेसफुली एग्जीक्यूटेड मतलब
यहां पर आर सई रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन वनटी
ये देखो आपने कमांड एग्जीक्यूट अगर और भी
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए आपको देखिए यहां पर मैं
क्या करता हूं अभी और कोई कमांड ऐड करता
हूं गेट यूआईडी रखते हैं हम जो विंडो की
कमांड है गेट यू आईडी देखिए हिट
एंटर गेट य आईडी नॉट रगना इंटरनल और
एक्सटर्नल
कमांड ऑपरेबल प्रोग्राम और बैच फाइल ओके
गेट यू आईडी काम इसमें नहीं कर रही है ओके
सिस इंफो हम करते हैं अगर पॉसिबल होगा
तो देखिए
नाउ तो बेसिकली आईएफ कन्फी काम कर गया
मतलब यहां पर चांसेस है रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यू आप ट्राई कर सकते हो ओके तो अभी
उसके अलावा क्या कर सकते हो आप एसएमबी मैप
हाइफ एच हेल फाइल देखेंगे हम तो और भी
क्या इंफॉर्मेशन कर सकते हो एक ऑप्शन था
हान एल लिस्ट ऑल ड्राइव्स ऑन द स्पेसिफाइड
होस्ट लिस्ट ऑल ड्राइव्स ऑन द स्पेसिफाइड
होस्ट तो हम कैसे कर सकते हैं देखिए तो हम
कर सकते हैं इसको ये रहा नाउ यहां पर हान
एल यूज कर सकते हैं
कैपिटल हाइन कैपिटल एल
देखिए यह एसएमबी मैप की कहानी एसएमबी मैप
टूल को आप क्या कर सकते हो इस तरीके से
यूज कर सकते हो यहां पर देखिए ओनली सी
ड्राइव मिली है ओनली ओनली सी ड्राइव इसके
अलावा और भी कोई इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली
लोकल ड्राइव कौन सी है सी ड्राइव अगर कोई
भी फ्लैश ड्राइव होती है और भी कोई ड्राइव
मैप होती इसके साथ एसएमबी के थ्रू तो वह
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती अभी आप चाहो तो
क्या कर सकते हो इनको एक्सेस भी कर सकते
हो फॉर एग्जांपल कैसे एक्सेस कर सकते हो
देखो अभी मैं हान आ यूज करूंगा देन किसको
ट्राई करता हूं यूज करने की कोश सी ड्राइव
सी ड्राइव थी यहां पर सी और डॉलर सिंबल था
उसके
सामने ओके यह रहा यह वाली थी और उसके बाद
मैं क्या करता टर
देखिए यह रहा हमने सक्सेसफुली एक्सेस कर
लिया देखो सी ड्राइव ड्राइड परमिशन है अब
यह देखो रि साइकिल बिन बूट बूट मैनेजर
डॉक्यूमेंट सेटिंग ग्लास फिश यह देखो ओपन
जेडी के सिक्स लॉग प्रोग्राम फाइल्स
प्रोग्राम डाटा रिकवरी स्टार्ट अप सिस्टम
वॉल्यूम इंफॉर्मेशन टूल्स
यूजर्स विंडोस दे लॉट ऑफ इफ
तो इस तरीके से हमने क्या किया शेयर को भी
एक्सेस कर लिया समझ समझ आ रहा है हम क्या
क्या कर सकते हैं अगर हम चाहे तो क्या कर
सकते हैं कि अपने डिवाइस पर क्या करेंगे
बैक डोर कोई भी रिवर्स सेल सेल की फाइल
क्रिएट करेंगे और इसके ऊपर क्या करेंगे
डिलीवर कर देंगे और हम क्या करते
सक्सेसफुली एक सेल एस्टेब्लिश करेंगे सेशन
इब्लिस कर लेंगे जिससे हम क्या कर सकते
हैं अपनी कमांड रन कर सकते हैं रिवर्स सेल
कनेक्शन या बैक डोर कनेक्शन एब्लिश कर
सकते हैं तो अी इस क्लास का पार्ट नहीं है
मैं जस्ट ये एमरे परफॉर्मेंस आपको दिखा
रहा हूं कि हम कैसे एमरे परफॉर्म करते हैं
एसएमबी के थ्रू और भी बहुत कुछ कर सकते हो
आप इसकी हेल्प से तो हम इसको आने वाली
क्लासेस में यूज करेंगे तो आपको मैंने
बताया जस्ट आप इस तरीके से इसको यूज कर
सकते हो तो सबको यहां तक क्लियर है अभी हम
शिफ्ट करेंगे सांबा के ऊपर यह विंडोज के
अंदर एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन कैसे कर सकते हैं
य मैंने आपको दिखा दिया सभी लोग कर लोगे
सारे मैंने ऑटो भी बता दिया ब्रूट फोर्स
भी बता दिया और कुछ और दूसरी टेक्निक से
हम अपकमिंग क्लासेस में पढ़ेंगे और मैंने
आपको एन मैप की व सारी स्क्रिप्ट बता द जो
आप यूज कर सकते हो लगभग जो मोस्ट पॉपुलर
स्क्रिप्ट है आप कहीं पर भी उसको एज ए बुक
बुकमार्क करके रखिए ए ए नोट्स बनाकर
रखिए एवरीवन गट क्लियर सबको समझ में आया
यहां
पर अभी हमारा नेक्स्ट टारगेट कौन सा रहेगा
सांबा ओके नेक्स्ट टारगेट कौन सा रहेगा
हमारा
सांबा और सबको पता है सांबा क्या
है एवरीवन
नोज तो अभी हम पिंग कर लेते हैं एक बार
सांबा को कि एक्टिव है या नहीं है पिंग
हाइ फन पोर्ट 139 क्योंकि इससे मतलब मुझे
और
445 445 और टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
192.168 181 य
रहा स्वा दवाज हम डाउट सेशन रख सकते हैं
बट 5 से 10 मिनट का कैसे रख सकते
हैं तो एक काम करते
हैं आप ग्रुप में हो उसमें क्या नाम है
अपना र
में लाइफ विद ए ट्विस्ट नो साइबर सिक्स
नो रेडी नो किस चीज के लिए नो बोल रहे आप
यार अखिलेश आप मेरे को पता नहीं क्यों
फोर्स करते हो थोड़ा सा मतलब की कहने के
लिए जब आप यह बताओ कि अभी फेज कौन सा कर
रहे हो
आप सर यह बता दो सेशन मेंटेन कैसे रखेंगे
आप कौन सा फेज करेंगे कर रहे हो बताओ आप
ही बताओ अखिलेश कि अभी हम किस फेज में है
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के क्या कोर्स ओवर हो
गया या कोर्स क्या बीच में आ ग जब मैंने
एक्सप्लेन नहीं किया बताओ
हां तो अखिलेश वेट कीजिए आप अगर ओनली
मेंटेन सेशन देखने के लिए आए हैं तो आई एम
सॉरी वह चीज देखने के लिए आपको
एटलीस्ट एटलीस्ट बताता हूं कि एन्यूमरेशन
प्लस में स्कैनिंग मान के चलिए 10 से 15
सेशन वेट करना पड़ेगा सब सेशन पहले से
पहले तो यह सीखो ग कि एक्सेस कैसे गेन
करते हैं सेशन मेंटेन करना तो बाद में
सिखाया जाएगा तो वो चीज के लिए आपको
धीरे-धीरे हो सकता है आपको और भी ज्यादा
क्लासेस वेट करना पड़ जाए क्योंकि मेरा एक
अप्रोच है एक पैटर्न में मैं काम करूंगा
अब इसी सर्फ इसी चीज को मैं आज नहीं
डिलीवर कर सकता आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट अगर
आपको इस चीज के लिए बुरा लग रहा है आई एम
रियली सॉरी फॉर दैट
वहां तक अभी तक हम अलेस पहुंचे नहीं है
अभी तो आप एमेशन फेज में हो सेकंड जो थर्ड
स्टेप है स्टेज है इसके बाद आपकी स्टार्ट
हो रही है सिस्टम हैकिंग जब स्कैनिंग आप
स्कैनिंग करना सीख जाओगे स्कैनिंग तो चलो
मैं आपको सिस्टम हैकिंग के दौरान सिखा
दूंगा
कि सॉरी वनटी स्कैनिंग कैसे करते हैं कोई
इशू नहीं है लेकिन उसके बाद हैकिंग
स्टार्ट होगी वहां पर आपकी जर्नी स्टार्ट
होती है एक्चुअल हैकिंग कि आपके पास लैब्स
होंगे सीटीएफ होंगे उस परे हम अपनी अपनी
एक एक स्ट्रेटजी बना के चलेंगे कि ओके आज
इस वनटी पर काम करेंगे आपको आईडिया हो
जाएगा पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन होती क्या है
एक्सप्लोइटेशन होती क्या है गेन एक्सेस
कैसे करते हैं प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कैसे
करते हैं प वेटिंग प पी वेटिंग कैसे करते
हैं सारी चीज मैं आपको स्टेप बाय स्टेप
बताऊंगा तो उस पेज में अब जल्दी हम एंटर
करेंगे अभी तक उस फेज में हम एंटर नहीं
किए हैं क्लास ओनली 13 क्लास हुई है कोर्स
बहुत बड़ा है
अभी हां एक्सप्लोइट ब सब कुछ सिखाऊंगा अगर
वेट वेट इट वेट तो सॉरी अभी थोड़ी देर के
मुझे डिस्टर्ब मत करो प्लीज मैं अभी सेशन
डिलीवर कर रहा हूं तो मुझे अभी फोकस करने
दी सांबा सांबा एक क्या है नक् यूटिलिटी
है मतलब कि ए सांबा क्या है एसएमबी है
आपको पता चल गया एसएमबी क्या होता है
सर्वर मैसेज ब्लॉक आपका प्रिंटर शेयर करने
के लिए फाइल शेयर करने के लिए विंडोज की
एक क्या है सर्विस है ये ओके इसको विंडो
के ऊपर यूज किया जाता है तो
करने के लिए कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए या
फाइल शेयर करने के लिए नाउ एडेज अभी सांबा
क्या इंडिपेंडेंट है टीसीपीआईपी प्रोटोकॉल
जो सूट है उसी का यूज करता है इंडिपेंडेंट
ओनली 4445 पोर्ट के ऊपर और भी ज्यादा आपको
डिटेल्स इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए जो अभी नो बोल
रहे थे तो प्लीज गो बैक टू योर डे च वन डे
11 वहां पर मैंने एक्सप्लेन किया है कि
सांबा और एसएमबी होते क्या है नेट वायस
होता क्या है पीपीटी के थ्रू काफी डिटेल
एक्सप्लेन किया है तो आप वहां से सीख सकते
हो मैं पूछ रहा था
किससे खुश ओके खुश भारद्वाज अगर आपने र का
सर तो नहीं मैं आपसे अभी लास्ट में बात
करता हूं खुश लास्ट तक बने रहिए एक बार
ओके तो थोड़ा सा सेशन आज कंप्लीट करना
हमें तो अभी हमने फाइंड आउट कर लिया कि
139 फिल्टर्ड पोर्ट नेट बायस एसएस और 445
ओपन ओके ये सांबा यहां पर एग्जैक्ट वर्जन
नहीं मेंशन किया लेकिन अगर एग्जैक्ट वर्जन
मुझे फाइंड आउट करना है एसएमबी का तो आपको
पता है कि सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन कैसे
करते हैं और भी ज्यादा डिटेल्स में और भी
डीप जाके तो वो आप कर सकते हो खुद से
क्योंकि वो मैं लास्ट क्लासेस में आपको
बता चुका हूं तो अभी हम क्या करने वाले
हैं अभी हम कुछ और स्क्रिप्ट देखने वाले
हैं ए मैप हान प कौन सा यूज करें 445 देन
हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट
और एक स्क्रिप्ट होती है एसएमबी हाइन ओस
डिस्कवरी ओस डिस्कवरी ओस डिस्कवरी एक
इंपोर्टेंट यह भी काफी इंपोर्टेंट
स्क्रिप्ट है ए स्क्रिप्ट
192.168 181 ट
एंटर यहां पर देखिए अभी एक चीज देखिए यहां
पर आपने एक चीज नोटिस की होगी आपको एक
नेगेटिव इंफॉर्मेशन गलत इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड कर रहा हैयक इसने बताया 445
टीसीपी ओपन पोर्ट एसएमबी होस डिस्कवरी में
विंडोज
6.1 क्योंकि एक लिनक्स इंप्लीमेंट बट यहां
पर इससे फिर भी एक्सपोज हो गया साबा
4.3.1 122 मतलब एक नटू मशीन है कंप्यूटर
नेम क्या है नटू नेटबस कंप्यूटर नेम क्या
है यह रहा डोमेन नेम क्या है नहीं है और
फुल्ली क्वालिफाइड डोमेन क्या हैट और यह
सिस्टम टाइम इन है तो मतलब कई जगह आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन खुद से लॉजिक लगाने होग देख
विंडोज भी और सांबा नट अभी सांबा का नाम
सुन के आप ऑटोमेटिक समझ जाना सांबा कहां
पर यूज किया जाता है नक् के ऊपर ओके तो
यहां पर वनटू का यूज किया जा रहा है तो
अभी मैं और भी क्या कर सकता हूं और भी जो
मैंने आपको बताया था जितनी भी अभी एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट बताई है लास्ट क्लास में आज भी
जो बताई और कल भी वो भी आप इसके ऊपर क्या
कर सकते हो परफॉर्म कर सकते हो जैसे कि
एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल्स जो स्क्रिप्ट है वो भी
आप इसके ऊपर क्या कर सकते हो परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो कैसे यरी
वह आप खुद से परफॉर्म कर लोगे या सारी
स्क्रिप्ट आज भी मुझे परफॉर्म करके दिखानी
पड़ेंगी
बताइए
प्रोटोकॉल बताइए जल्दी से चैट सेक्शन में
और आज डोंट वरी सेशन के एंड में मैं आपको
क्या बताऊंगा एक टास्क दूंगा जो करने के
लिए आपको 100% करना है वो खुद से तो यह
रहा मैक एड्रेस है यह भी क्या है एी वर्जन
वन का यूज कर रहा है डिफॉल्ट सेटिंग के
साथ और एक चीज है इस पर आपको क्या करना है
खुद से ट्राई करना वो एमएसएफ के थ्रू क्या
करना है क्या बोल सकते हैं
हम ब्रूट फोर्स इस पर भी आप कर सकते हो
मेटा स्लोट कंसोल के थ्रू क्या कर सकते हो
ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते हो ओके क्या कर सकते
हो आप ब्रूट फोर्स खुद से कर सकते
हो तो अभी मैं मेटा स्ड कंसोल को यूज करके
दिखाऊ या एमएसएफ कंसोल को यूज कर लोगे चलो
मैं आपको एक बार दिखा देता हूं एक बार हम
चेक करते
हैं सर्विस
स्टार्ट पोस्ट ओके सर सिस्टम
ओके सर्विस स्टार्ट हो गई है अभी आपको
इसका स्टेटस चेक करना तो भी चेक कर सकते
हो एमएस एफ डीबी उसके
बाद यह एंटर करके देख सकते हो आप स्टेटस
चेक कर सकते हो एमएसडीबी स्टेटस य
रहा देखिए सिस्टम एक्टिव है तो मैं सिफ
कंसोल को यूज करता हूं
कौन से लब की बात कर रहे हो अखिलेश जो अभी
मैं बात कर रहा हूं
यह तो मेरी जो मैं क्लासेस पढ़ा रहा हूं
ना अभी आप तो इनके स्क्रीनशॉट के लिए आप
अलाउड हो जो अभी मैं ू पर पढ़ा रहा हूं
अगर आप रेफरेंस के लिए इनका स्क्रीनशॉट
लेकर रखना चाहते हो अपने पास तो रख लीजिए
मुझे इससे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है क्योंकि
मेरी पर्सनल लैब सेटअप है तो नो इशू
ये रहा अभी इसमें एक ऑप्शंस होते हैं जैसे
कि एफ कंसोल किया मैं सर्च करता हूं सर्च
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
टाइप ऑक्सल उसके बाद नेम नेम क्या मेरा
एसएमबी ये रहा एसएमबी हो गया अभी मैं क्या
करता हूं इसमें एक और होगा एक नया नई चीज
दिखाता हूं यह मैंने आपको कवर कर दिया है
एसएमबी वर्जन आप इसमें भी फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो और एक और चीज होगा इसमें कहां गया
कहां
गया स्कैनर एसएमबी ओके एसएमबी लॉगिन एसम
बी
एनम ठीक है आप एक बार शेयर अमरेट करके देख
लीजिए इसमें
डायरेक्टली न य
35 यूज 35 ओके नाउ सो
ऑप्शन आप ब्रूट फोर्स खुद से ट्राई कर
सकते हो तो यहां पर आर होस्ट आपको सेट
करना पड़ेगा और पासवर्ड यूजर नेम अब आपके
पास है नहीं तो फिर भी हम फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करते हैं
सेट आर होस्ट 192.168
ड 181 हिट एंटर चलो यह हो गया अभी हम रन
कर देते हैं इसको तो कोई इनफॉर्म शेयर की
इंफॉर्मेशन हमें मिलेगी हम फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करते हैं अगर यह प्रोवाइड कर
पाता है
तो टाइम आउट दिखा रहा है क्योंकि मे बी
प्रॉब्लम इज दैट ओके य रहा प्रिंट पब्लिक
य डिस्क डब्लू डब् और आईपीसी स्कैन फोर ये
हो गया तो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो
इसके और भी जो मोड्स है इसपे आप क्या
ट्राई कर सकते हो ये रहा इसमें भी यूजर्स
नेम एंड पासवर्ड आप फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कर सकते हो या जो भी मैंने मॉड्यूस
बताए थे एसएमबी के एसएमबी वर्जन एसएमबी
लॉगिन या ये वाले एसएमबी लॉगइन एसएमबी
एम्स एसएमबी सस अभी यूज करके आपको दिखा
दिया तो ये सारे के सारे आप इसके ऊपर भी
यूज कर सकते हो तो मैं अभी इसको यूज करके
नहीं दिखा रहा हूं अभी मैं कुछ और नए
टूल्स की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा
हूं इसको एग्जिट कर देता हूं उसके बाद हम
यूज करते
हैं एसएमबी क्लाइंट के बारे में सबको पता
है एसएमबी क्लाइंट नाम सुना है कभी आपने
एसएमबी हम
क्लाइंट एसबी क्लाइंट उसके बाद हाइन हाइन
हेल्प देखो अब ये क्या काम करता यह भी एक
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है और काफी
इंपोर्टेंट टूल्स है यह भी काफी एसएमबी
क्लाइंट क्या है सर्विस औरन पासवर्ड ऑप्शन
ये रहा एसएमबी क्लाइंट का मैं आपको मेन
पेज ओपन करके दिखा देता
हूं मेन
एसएमबी क्लाइंट यह देखिए एसएमबी क्लाइंट
क्या है एक एफटीपी लाइक क्लाइंट टू एक्सेस
एसएमबी या सीआईएफएस रिसोर्स सर्वर जैसे
आपने एफटीपी कभी यूज किया होगा तो जैसे
एटीपी को एक्सेस कर सकते हो इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करने के लिए फाइल डाउनलोड करने के
लिए अपलोड करने उसी तरीके से ये उसी टाइप
की एक सर्विस है या उसी टाइप की एक
यूटिलिटी है आप उसको यूज कर सकते हो तो आप
काफी डिटेल्स में पढ़ सकते हैं इसको आप
चाहो तो देखो डिस्क्रिप्शन क्या है दिस
टूल इज अ पार्ट ऑफ सांबा सूट एसएमबी
क्लाइंट इज ए क्लाइंट देन कैन टॉक टू एन
एसएमबी या सीआईएफएस सर्वर इट ऑफर्स एन
इंटरफेस सिमिलर टू दैट ऑफ द एफटीपी
प्रोग्राम ऑपरेशंस इंक्लूड थिंग्स लाइक
गेटिंग फाइल्स फ्रॉम द सर्वर टू द लोकल
मशीन पुटिंग फाइल्स फ्रॉम द लोकल मशीन तो
यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करता है तो
इसको मैं आपको यूज करके दिखा देता हूं एक
बार कैसे यूज करते हैं तो एक बार क क्यों
किया अभी मैं इसके लिए एक ऑप्शन यूज
करूंगा इसमें सबसे पहले हाइन एच सबसे पहले
हम यूज करेंगे एक हाइन एच तो हाइन एच है
इसमें
शायद यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा हान होगा एम एम
एम एंड डी डी डीडी जी ओके इ देर एनी
ऑप्शन इसकी चिट चट आप देख सकते हो हान
इसमें है या नहीं नहीं है इसमें हान एच
नहीं
है ओके हान ए तो हेल्प मैन के लिए होता
आईम सॉरी फॉर दैट एसएमबी
क्लाइंट उसके बाद हाइन एल कैपिटल एल यह तो
ऑप्शन है इसमें यह रहा यह रहा
इधर लिस्ट होट गेट ए लिस्ट ऑफ शेयर्स
अवेलेबल ऑन होस्ट ओके शेयर की लिस्ट आपको
प्रोवाइड करने की कोशिश करेगा
19216801 और हान ए हाइन ए क्यों लिख रहा
हूं ये देखो नो पासवर्ड मलब डोंट आस्क फॉर
ए पासवर्ड बिना पासवर्ड के आप ट्राई करो
इसको हिट एंटर देखिए आप इसको भी यूज कर
सकते हो इसने बता दिया प्रिंट पब्लिक और
आईपीसी अभी री कनेक्टिंग विद द एसएमबी फॉर
वर्क ग्रुप लिस्टिंग ओके अभी हमारे पास
यही इंफॉर्मेशन है उसके अलावा और भी क्या
कर सकते हैं हम बस अभी क्या हमारे पासस
इंफॉर्मेशन हो चाहिए यूजर नेम ए पासवर्ड
तो और भी बहुत कुछ कर सकते हैं जो हम क्या
करते हैं मैं आपको जस्ट इंफॉर्मेशन दे रहा
हूं कि एसएमबी क्लाइंट भी एक टूल्स होता
है जिसको हम क्या करने वाले हैं अपने
हैकिंग के सिस्टम जो हैकिंग होगी उसमें
यूज करने वाले हैं उससे हम शेयर की
इंफॉर्मेशन ट्राई करेंगे या इसके ऊपर कोई
फाइल प्लांट करने की कोशिश करेंगे सर्वर
के
ऊपर तो उसके बाद हम आपको अभी आपने सुना
होगा एक आरपीसी क्लाइंट सुना है
आरपीसी
क्लाइंट आरपीसी क्लाइंट हान एच एक टूल और
होता है यह रहा यह क्या है आरपीसी क्लाइंट
हान एच ये रहा नाउ अब इसके बारे में आपको
थोड़ा सा पढ़ना तो मेन की मेन पेज प जाइए
इसके ये क्या काम करता है
आरपीसी क्लाइंट हिट एंटर ये रहा टूल फॉर
एग्जीक्यूटिंग क्लाइंट साइड एमएस आरपीसी
फंक्शन
ओके इसका काम क्या है इज यूटिलिटी
इंटेंशनली डेवलप टू टेस्ट आरपीसी फंक्शन
इन सांबा इट सेल्फ इट हैज अंडरगोन सेवरल
स्टेजेस ऑफ डेवलपमेंट एंड स्टेबिलिटी मेनी
सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हैव नाउ रिटन
स्क्रिप्ट अराउंड इट टू मैनेज विंडोज एंटी
क्लाइंट ओके तो बेसिकली डायरेक्टली
इनडायरेक्टली सबका एक ही काम है बट मैं
क्या करता हूं मल्टीपल टूल्स को आपको
एक्सप्लेन कर रहा हूं वो भी इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करने के लिए अभी मैं यूज करके
दिखाता हूं इसको आरपीसी
क्लाइंट उसके बाद हाइन यू अभी यूजर नेम
ब्लैंक छोड़ रहा हूं मेरे पास यूजर नेम
नहीं है हाइन एंड नो पासवर्ड उसके बाद
टारगेट ओके व्हाट हैपन 192.168
181 ओके हिट एंटर अभी यहां पर कनेक्ट हो
गया हम इसके साथ अभी यहां पर क्वेश्चन
मार्क शो करता हूं हेल्प फाइल देखने के
लिए हिट एंटर यह हेल्प फाइल आपकी आरपीसी
क्लाइंट की देखो बहुत बड़ी हेल्प फाइल है
ना बहुत बड़ी हेल्प फाइल है जिसको आप क्या
कर सकते हो यूज कर सकते हो देखो बहुत बड़ी
हेल्प फाइल है तो कुछ इसके कमांड जो हम
यूज करके दिखाते जैसे एस आरवी इंफो सर्वर
क्यूरी इंफॉर्मेशन या एनम डोम यूजर्स होगा
इसमें यह रहा कहां गया य ईएम लुक अप लुक
अप बाइंडिंग्स और इको डाटा और यह रहा यह
रहा और भी नीचे चलते हैं हम लॉट ऑफ ऑप्शंस
आप इसके अंदर यूज कर सकते हो अभी क्या है
बहुत ज्यादा बहुत ज्यादा ऑप्शन इसके अंदर
आप खुद से इसको यूज करके देखिए इसकी चीट
शट आप मेंशन कर लीजिए कहीं पर भी इंटरनेट
पर सर्च करोगे ना आपको मिल जाएगी तो कैसे
मैं जैसे यूज करता हूं एस आरवी इंफो एस
आरवी इंफो हिट एंटर कीया देखिए उन
प्लेटफॉर्म आईडी 5g जो उसका वर्जन अभी
हमें एग्जैक्ट वर्जन मिल गया 6.1 और यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे लिए बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट होती है एक्सप्लोइटेशन के लिए
एक्सप्लोइट करने के लिए मशीन को क्योंकि
इससे रिलेटेड हम एक्सप्लोइट फाइंड आउट
करते हैं अगर उसके बाद मैं यहां पर करना
चाहता हूं
एनम एनम डोम यूजर डोम यूजर यह रहा यूजर्स
हिड एंटर यह देखो यह यूजर्स है ये उसकी
आईडी
है अभी मुझे पढ़ना नहीं आ रहा ये उसके बाद
य लुक अप
नेम्स तो अभी देख सकता ये भी होगा तो लुक
अप नेम्स कुछ ऐसे करके
होगा लुक अपस नेम्स
होगा ओके यहां पर हमें एक आईडिया आईडिया
लेते कि हमारे पास इसमें कोई एडमिन करके
है क्या ये रहा नो एंटी स्टेटस नॉन मैप
नॉट मैप तो इस तरीके से आप इसको भी यूज कर
सकते हो इसको मैं एग्जिट कर देता हूं इसको
मैं क्या कर देता हूं अभी के लिए एग्जिट
कर देता हूं और अभी सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
एक और चीज दिखाता हूं लास्ट जो टूल है मैं
आपको शो करने वाला हूं व एनम फ
एक अच्छी चीटशीट है nm4
linux.com फ
इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर इंफॉर्मेशन डिटेक्टिंग इफ
होस्ट इज इन ए वर्क ग्रुप ऑफ ए डोमेन
आईडेंटिफाइंग द रिमोट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
पासवर्ड पॉलिसी रिट्रीव और यह सारे सारे
ऑप्शंस आप इसके साथ यूज कर सकते हो मैं
आपको एक दो ऑप्शन यूज करके दिखाऊंगा बट यह
चीट चीट मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं और
यह आपको किसी भी सीटीएफ में या कहीं पर भी
एग्जाम में या रियल लाइफ में भी आपको वेरी
वेरी हेल्पफुल मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता
हूं इसको सेव कर लेना
आप यह
रहा सबको मिल गया
सबको मिल गया
स्क्रीन एक्सेस कर पा रहे
हो ओके वेरी गुड चलो तो अभी हम क्या करते
हैं इसको यूज करके दिखाते हैं तो दिस द
लास्ट टूल फॉर द टुडे इसको मैं क्लियर कर
देता हूं अभी तो एम फ नेक्स
हाम फॉर लिनेक्स और इसका ऑप्शन है अभी जो
ऑप्शन में यूज करने वाला हूं व एक ऑप्शन
है
इसका
हाइन एक हेल फाइल ओपन कर दे इसके एक बार
आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा अदर वाइज तो इसके
हेल्प फाइल में हम क्या करते हैं यह रहा
एक
और ताकि आपको सबकी चीजें क्लियर हो
जाए यह रहा अभी क्या है ओस इंफॉर्मेशन हाई
ओ यूज कर सकता हूं मैं इसके साथ देखो एनम
फ लिनेक्स
एनम फ लिनेक्स उसके बाद हाइन ओ
192.168 181 हिट एंटर देखिए टारगेट आईडी
आर आईडी उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करर
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड अभी नॉन यूजर नेम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर गेस्ट दज आर द रूट अभी
बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करता है
देखो यह
रहा यह क्या है यूजर्स नेम है किसके ऊपर
आपके न टू मशीन के ऊपर वर्ग गप इंफॉर्मेशन
कुछ नहीं है सेशन चेक पासवर्ड नील है यूजर
नेम नील है डोमेन वर्क ग्रुप है इसका भी
और डोमेन की एस आईडी नहीं मिली हमें ओस
इंफॉर्मेशन टू है वर्जन ये है हमारे पास
ये इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल गई अभी मैं क्या
कर सकता हूं यहां पर हाइन य का भी यूज कर
सकता हूं हाइन यू अब य हान यू क्या होता
है देखो प
टर्मिनल अरे यार यह
रहा इसको छोटा कर देते हैं इसको क्लोज कर
देते हैं यह रहा और हाइफ यू ऑप्शन होता है
एक इसमें आपको दिखा देता हूं मैं गेट द
यूजर लिस्ट आपको यूजर लिस्ट चाहिए तो हम
क्या कर सकते हैं वो भी फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं ये रहा कैसे एम फ लिनक्स
सबको समझ में आ रहा
है यह रहा हाइ फन कैपिटल य यह
रहा देखिए
वही सेम इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा
है अभी डिटेल इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड कर रहा
आपको देखिए वही है यूजर नेम वही है नाउ नो
नोनो नहीं नहीं नहीं यहां पर हमने कनेक्ट
करने की कोशिश की थी य टारगेट इंफॉर्मेशन
ये यूजर्स की ओनली यूजर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन
इसने प्रोवाइड कर दी एंड दिस इज ओके
चेकिंग चेकिंग ओके नाउ सेम अभी अगर आप
चाहो तो एक हान एस ऑप्शन हो गया हान एस भी
यूज कर सकते हो इसके साथ अभी आपको खुद से
फाइंड आउट करना
है मैं लास्ट कमांड रन करके दिखा रहा हूं
उसके बाद हम सेशन को आज ओवर करेंगे आपके
डाउट सेशन लेते
हुए यह
रहा तो अभी मुझे यह बताइए सभी को क्लियर
है कि अगर आपको मैं बोलता हूं कि आपको
एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन करना है चाहे वह आपका
विंडोज हो चाहे लिनक्स हो चाहे उसमें
सांबा आए या एसएमबी आए दोनों चीज तो एक ही
है क्या आप उस पे डिटेल एन्यूमरेशन कर
लोगे टारगेट के ऊपर यस या नो सभी के सभी
दे 26 स्टूडेंट्स मुझे आंसर
चाहिए क्या
सभी एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म कर पाओगे मैं सबसे
पूछ रहा
हूं एवरीवन
कर
लोगे क्योंकि जब मेरे साथ आप लाइव में
जुड़ होगे लाइव क्लास में तो मैं आप लोगों
से पूछूंगा इवन टूल्स की कमांड सब कुछ
पूछूंगा मैं मेरी आदत ऐसी होती है
जिन्होंने मेरे साथ क्लासेस ली है
जिन्होंने खासकर एंड्राइड पन टेस्टिंग
पढ़ी है मुझसे एंड्राइड हैकिंग पढी है
ब्लैक ट हैकिंग एंड की तो वह अच्छे से
जानते मेरे
को ओके तो वेरी गुड देखो ये डिटेल
इंफॉर्मेशन
मतलब काफी अच्छा टूल है अगर इंफॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल है ना सिस्टम के अंदर देखो एक चीज
मान के ज अगर सिस्टम के अंदर वल बिलिटी है
या सर्विसेस मिस कंफर्ड है तो वो आपको भर
भर के इंफॉर्मेशन देंगी जब सीटीएफ के केस
में जो आपको मिलती है तो उसी प्रकार से यह
काफी काफी हेल्पफुल है आपको अभी भी बहुत
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास मिल रही है देखो
प्रिंट प्रिंटर ड्राइवर पब्लिक
डब्ल्यूडब्ल्यू आईपीसी सर्विस और ये रहा
देखो अटेम्प्टिंग टू मैप शेयर्स ऑन व बट
डिनाइड डिनाइड ओके नाउ कां कैन नॉट
अंडरस्टैंड रिस्पांस तो मतलब इतनी ज्यादा
इसमें इफॉर्म क्योंकि जस्ट नेबल मशीन इसके
ऊपर कुछ है नहीं तो आज का सेशन इतना ही था
तो आई होप सभी इसको कर लोगे जितने भी
टूल्स जितनी भी कमांड्स जितनी भी
स्क्रिप्ट जितने भी मॉड्यूल मैं सब कुछ
आपको बताया तीन क्लास के अंदर तो आप सभी
परफॉर्म कर पाओगे और मुझे अभी मैं चलता
हूं डाउट सेशन पर अभी जिसके जो भी डाउट
आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो ओके जो भी डाउट्स आप
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो खुश बार दवाज आप भी पूछ
सकते हो जिसका जो भी डाउट है मुझसे अी पूछ
सकता है नेक्स्ट फ मिनट 10 मिनट ले लिया
अगर आपके डाउट ज्यादा होंगे तो आई विल
एक्सप्लेन नेक्स्ट 10 मिनट अगर आपका डाउट
नहीं हो हम सेशन को एंड कर देंगे आज का
सेशन इतना ही होगा ब बहुत ही कम स्टूडेंट
थे तो इस वजह से मुझे अभी मैं अपनी मर्जी
से सेशन लूंगा
नेक्स्ट अभी मैंने आप लोगों के लिए आप
लोगों की रिक्वेस्ट पर एक दिन छोड़ के एक
दिन सेशन मैंने प्लान किया बट आप लोगों का
रिस्पांस बहुत स्लो
था बताइए
आप डेफिनेटली इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक पहुंच
जाओगे एडवांस लेवल पर अगर आप लोगों मेरे
साथ चलना है आप लोगों को और भी एडवांस
जाना है मतलब एक प्रोफेशनल बनना है जहां
पर आपको इवन मैं बात करूं कि एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग सीखनी है
या बात रहे कि हम तो अभी क्या कि
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल पर क्या करेंगे कि
बीच-बीच का एक्सप्लेन करेंगे एक रिस्पांस
रखेंगे कि
कि ऐसे किया जाता है किसको लिनक्स
प्रिविलेज एलेशन या विंडोज प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन अगर उसके बारे में डिटेल्स
पढ़ना है कि बिल्कुल डिटेल्स में वो भी
वोह सारे एडवांस चीज में आते हैं या पावर
सेल जो यूज होता है उसकी बहुत सारी
स्क्रिप्ट होती है उसका क्या रोल है इवन
एक्सप्लोइट डेवलपमेंट होती है बफर जो
ओवरफ्लो वटी है उसको उसके ऊपर कैसे
डेवलपमेंट किए जाते हैं थोड़े बहुत तो वो
सारी चीज अगर आपको डीप में चाहिए तो फिर व
एडवांस कोर्स है अगर वह आप सीखना चाहते तो
मोस्ट वेलकम इस कोर्स के बाद हम उधर शिफ्ट
करेंगे बट वह फ्री नहीं
होगा ओके डाउट अभी मैं लेना स्टार्ट सर
कोर्स पूरा होने तक हम आपका जवाब दे दिया
हां कुश भारद्वाज आप बताइए आपका डाउट क्या
है अखिलेश राव सर
कमांड या स्क्रिप्ट की इंफॉर्मेशन
विच यूज करना हो तो कौन
कोई उसके लिए कमांड बताइए स्क्रिप्ट की
इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए मैंने आपको बताया था
अगर आपको एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट की इंफॉर्मेशन
चाहिए कि उसका काम क्या है तो आपको क्या
करना है एन मैप उसके बाद हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट इक्वल हाइन इंफो इसके बाद
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम प्रोवाइड कर दीजिए जिस
भी स्क्रिप्ट की आपको इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए
आपको मिल
जाएगी न उस कोर्स का नाम ऑलरेडी है
डीसीएसपी जिसको हम बोलते हैं डेफ
सर्टिफाइड सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल वही
सब पूछिए पूछिए खुश भारत बार पूछिए आपका
क्या डाउट था सर आप संडे को हमारे डाउट
सेशन ले लीजिए तो पूछ लीजिए अभी हमारे पास
आज टाइम है आज हमारे सेशन बहुत छोटा सेशन
है क्योंकि मैं ओनली प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट
करना
था पूछिए
पूछिए यार इतने पैसे आप लोगों के मैंने
बचा दिए एटलीस्ट कि आप लोगों को तो अभी
मैं आप लोगों की जगह होता ना कि
कंट्रीब्यूट कर देता मैं कि एटलीस्ट जितना
जिसका मन कर रहा है ना कि मेरे पास इतनी
हो सकता है कि सर आप लोगों ने हमारे न लाख
र या 80000 या 0000 आप लोगों ने कोर्स में
वेस्ट होने से बचा लिए मैं आपकी जगह होता
ना तो मैं डेफिनेटली क्या करता कि मैं
वॉलंटिली मेरे पास जितनी मतलब हिम्मत है
1000 2000 5000 10000 व्हाट एवर मेरे पास
जितनी होती मैं वॉलंटिली इकट्ठा करके
डोनेट कर देता बट मैं आपको क्या बोल रहा
हूं मुझे डोनेशन नहीं चाहिए आप सिर्फ इतना
करो उन पैसों को पेरेंट से लो आपके पास
टाइम है नेक्स्ट फोर टू फ मिनट मंथ आपके
पास टाइम है उनको इकट्ठा करके अपने पास
रखिए एज ए सेविंग और प्रोफेशनल कोर्स पर
इन्वेस्ट कीजिए मैं आपको सिफ यह बोल रहा
हूं
उसके लिए अभी वेट करना पड़ेगा अभी खुश
भारद्वाज उसको अभी वेट करना पड़ेगा हां
ओके ओके एक चीज याद आ गई मुझे चलो आप
लोगों का टारगेट मेरे पास आ गया टास्क
आपको जो टास्क टास्क करना था ना ट्राई हैक
मी पर आपको टास्क परफॉर्म करना है और यह
सभी का टास्क है यह आपको परफॉर्म करके
मुझे लिंक दिन पर और डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी
दोनों को लिंक दिन पर टैग करना है जितने
भी अग सिंसस है आपको मैंने पिछली बार भी
बताया था एक लैब थी ना तो उसी लैब को अभी
आपको ओनली एसएमबी वाले पार्ट को क्या करना
है उसमें सॉल्व करना है तो वे द सर्च
पार्ट और यह रहा
ओके वे द नेटवर्क सर्विसेस पार्ट यह रहा
दिस दिस द पार्ट ऑफ नेटवर्क सर्विस फ्री
लैब्स है आपको यह कहना टास्क नंबर वन नहीं
टास्क नंबर टू टास्क नंबर थ्री टास्क नंबर
फोर चारों टास्क आपको क्या करना है
नेक्स्ट क्लास से पहले आपको कंप्लीट करने
हैं यह आप लोगों टास्क
है यह आपको करने है हो जाएंगे सबको अपना
होमवर्क मिल गया आप लोग बोले सर हमारे पास
लैब्स नहीं है एसएमबी की कहां पर
एन्यूमरेशन प्रैक्टिस करें यहां पर कर
सकते हो ओके हो जाएगा बिफोर नेक्स्ट क्लास
एवरीवन कुस एक काम कीजिए थोड़ा सा वेट
कीजिए कोर्स के एंड तक तो आपको ये सारी
टेक्निक्स आ
जाएंगी ओके कोर्स में आप सीख जाओगे
[संगीत]
और सर मेटा फ्लोट का जैसे एक्सप्लोइट होता
है वैसे क्या विंडोज का भी होता
है मतलब मैं समझा नहीं आपका सवाल ही नहीं
समझ पाया मैं
हुसन सवाल को थोड़ा सा डिटेल में
पूछिए चैट में शेयर कर दे लिंक लो कंट्रोल
सी ना लो यह
आपका सबको मिल गया
हो जाएगा टास्क और अगर आप लोग यह नहीं कर
पाए ना और यहां पर आपने चीटिंग की कि आपको
मतलब कुछ समझ में नहीं आ रहा तो मतलब आप
फिर कुछ नहीं कर सकते सच बता रहा हू आपको
फिर कुछ नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि जो कुछ
मैंने बताया ना उसका इसमें बिल्कुल 20 30
पर ही होगा देखो ध्यान से देखोगे एनम फन
को यूज करना यहां पर कर लो इजली आप कर लो
एसएमबी क्लाइंट मैं आपको बता चुका हूं
शेयर एक्सेस करना सिखा देंगे आपको आपको
यहां पर कुछ एडिशनल इंफॉर्मेशन भी मिलेगी
सीखने को ये रहा नमरे में ये देखो
एक्सप्लोइट करना भी सिखा रहे हैं तो आपको
अच्छा सीखे देखो तो यह सारी की सारी चारों
चारों लैब आपको करनी है टास्क नंबर टू
टास्क नंबर थ्री टास्क नंबर फोर आपको यहां
पर करना
है डाउट पूछिए किसी को कोई डाउट है तो अदर
वाइज मैं सेशन को एंड करता हूं
फिर आर्यन सिंपल है पैरेट ओस को इंस्टॉल
करना पुराने अभी लेटेस्ट वर्जन को मत करो
लेटेस्ट वर्जन में प्रॉब्लम है नहीं हो पा
रहा इंस्टॉल करने में बहुत सारी प्रॉब्लम
है तो कोई भी पुराना वर्जन लीजिए जैसे कि
मेरा पैरेट ओस का वर्जन मैं आपको बता देता
हूं दि द माय पैरेट ओस
वर्जन यह
रहा यह रहा वर्जन 6.2 यूज कर रहा हूं तो
आप 6.2 को यूज कीजिए यह पुराना वर्जन है
स्टेबल वर्जन है तो जैसे आप काली को यूज
करते हो ना सेम उतने ज्यादा भी स्टेप नहीं
है इसमें आप सिंपली जो भी स्टेप यह फॉलो
करने के लिए बोल रहा सिंपली बस सारे स्टेप
फॉलो करो फॉलो करने के बाद जैसे ही आप
पैरेट ओस को ओपन करोगे यहां पर एक फाइल
आती है इंस्टॉल करने की फाइल होती है
सिंपली यह ऑन हो जाता है ऑन होने के बाद
इंस्टॉल करने की फाइल होती है उस परे डबल
क्लिक करोगे तब इसके अंदर जो भी
प्रोग्राम्स है या जो भी एप्लीकेशन वो
सारे इंस्टॉल होते हैं इसका थोड़ा इतना ही
डिफरेंट प्रोसीजर इससे ज्यादा कोई डिफरेंट
प्रोसीजर नहीं
है अगर विंडोज डि फाइंडर फिल्टर कर रहा है
तो मैंने आपको एक बताया था अगर ध्यान से
अगर आपने एन मैप को पढ़ा होगा तो वहां पर
मैंने एक्सप्लेन भी किया था आप किसमें
भेजना है पैकेट को उसमें ट्राई करना
है एक टेक्निक बताई छोटे-छोटे पैकेट्स में
भेजना है
उनको और आपको तब तक ट्राई करना है कि वह
क्या है कि अभी वह किस पैकेट पर जाके
फिल्टर नहीं करता आपको व खुद से फाइंड आउट
करना
होगा अगर देखो फायरवॉल एक्टिव होगी तो
स्क्रिप्ट क्या है कि इजन वाली स्क्रिप्ट
काम में आएंगी ओके और अदर वाइज क्या है कि
फायरवॉल एक्टिव तो आपको पता चल जाएगा
फायरवॉल एक्टिव है फिर आपको क्या है कि
अदर टेक्निक्स को यूज करने पड़ेंगे फ
फायरवॉल इजन वाली तो वो भी हम क्या है
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में सीख लेंगे निकलते
निकलते कोस फिनिश करते
करते मिटर प्रेटर सेल क्रिएट करना मैंने
आपको सिखाया नहीं कैसे हो
होगा काली में शायद लेटेस्ट वर्जन में
प्रॉब्लम है मैं अभी अभी काली मैं बंद कर
रहा हूं मैं पुराना वर्जन इंस्टॉल करूंगा
क्योंकि लास्ट क्लास में बहुत फ्लकचुएशन
हुआ काली के साथ तो मैं ओल्ड वर्जन ही यूज
करूंगा क्यों मैं इससे पहले ओल्ड यूज करता
था मैंने इसको शिफ्ट किया अपग्रेड किया
मैं इसको जैसे अपग्रेड भी करता हूं तो
ऑटोमेटिक अपग्रेड होता नहीं पर और सारे
प्रॉब्लम स्टार्ट हो जाती है तो बट अभी ये
स्टेबल वर्जन नहीं है तो मैं इसे डिसएग्री
कर रहा हूं
अभी तो हिमकर एक काम करो आपने जस्ट अभी
स्टार्ट किया है तो लाइव क्लास एक भी मत
मिस कीजिए और जितना जल्दी हो सके ज्यादा
क्लासेस नहीं ओनली 12 क्लास हुई हैं
जिनमें से क्या कि ओनली जो इफेक्टिव क्लास
रहती है वन या न 11 आवर्स की रहती है तो
स्टार्टिंग और एंड की थोड़ी चैट होती है
आपके रिप्लाई देने होते हैं या थोड़ी बहुत
इंफॉर्मेशन पास करनी होती है तो आप इजली
कवर कर सकते हो नेक्स्ट वन वीक में थोड़ा
सा अगर ट्राई करोगे
तो यस फ्रेगमेंटेशन का यूज कर सकते
हो पैट सके आपने सॉल्व कर लिया तो आप उसको
शेयर कर दीजिए और दूसरा क्या है कि आपको
एक और चीज बता देता हूं आप चाहो तो इधर भी
कर सकते
हो अटैक डिफेंस की लैब होती है ठीक है तो
यहां पर अगर कुछ फ्री लब होती है तो यहां
पर जो किसी यहां पर आप क्या करोगे लॉग इन
करोगे साइन इन करोगे तो साइन इन करने के
बाद वहां पर ओनली आप क्या कर सकते हो जो
नमरे पार्ट होगा जब आप
है तो वहां पर भी आप प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हो और किसी का कोई सवाल
तो आपको फिर आप जो सॉल्व कर चुके तो कोई
इशू नहीं है जिनको अगर पहले से ही पता है
य आप ऑलरेडी सॉल्व कर चुके तो शायद आप
लोगों को इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए नहीं तो
जिन्होंने नहीं किया है जिनको प्रैक्टिस
करनी है तो व प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हैं अभी तो आप बहुत सारे लोग होगे जब हम
कुछ सीटीएस करेंगे तो हो सकता है कि आप
लोग सॉल्व कर चुके होंगे तो आप लोग उसमें
कोई इंटरेस्ट नहीं होगा तो इट्स ओके यू
कैन लीव इट
सेशन को एंड करें
फिर और नेक्स्ट क्लास अभी मैं आपको नहीं
बता रहा कब होगी
क्योंकि सच में आम वेरी डिमोटिवेट मैं सच
में बहुत डिमोटिवेट हुआ हूं 28 35 तक आगे
रुक जाते हो तुम लोग यार हद होती
है इससे अच्छा तो मैं एक काम करूंगा ना
किसी टी में जाके मैं बोलूंगा कि फ्री में
पढ़ा दूंगा तो लाइव क्लासेस उधर या मैं वो
करूंगा तो उधर भी नहीं है 500 500 600 600
स्टूडेंट आ जाएंगे पढ़ने के लिए फ्री में
और उनको आप लोगों से बेटर पढ़ा दूंगा और
तुम आप लोगों से बेटर
पढ़ेंगे यहां कुछ लोग आते हैं सब जस्ट कुछ
यहां पर स्पैमिंग करने के लिए कुछ